this is the last question we're going to
have a look at from this particular
practice exam it's a pretty
straightforward integral but you have to
choose the substitution and it's not
told to you what substitution to use and
that is actually one of the reasons why
i want to show you this question and
work through it because there's a couple
of different good candidates for a
substitution let's have a look
evaluate the integral from 1 to 2 of
it's 1 over like there's a 1 just kind
of hiding here right 1 over this x
1 plus log x or squared function with
respect to x okay so let's just grab a
hold of this
and copy that and let's pop it into
where we're writing our solutions
this'll do
okay fantastic
what did we say i think this was part f
now as i just mentioned um the tricky
but also cool thing about this is that
you're not told what uh substitution is
appropriate in fact you're not told to
use substitution at all but when you
have a look at this hopefully you sort
of recognize that this is not one of the
standard forms for something to
integrate so you're going to have to do
something to sort of manipulate it to
make it easier to work with okay
and the first instinct is to say well
there's log x terms in there gross
usually log x terms are things we try to
avoid integrating differentiation is
fine but to integrate them you know it's
like oh i'm going to have to do
integration by parts here okay but
you've got a function of a function and
that's sort of what clues you in that
just trying to go straight at this with
integration by parts is not going to be
very useful okay so what i'm going to do
is suggest that that that term right
there
1 plus log x
that's being squared the function of a
function there is going to be useful to
choose a substitution so let's go ahead
and work out what happens with the
substitution and then we'll just sub all
of our bits in you know the boundaries
our integrand here and then also change
the variable of integration so here we
go
if we just take this and we define that
we'll say let u equal 1 plus log x
let's see what we get out of this for
starters it's fairly easy to change the
variable of integration because when you
differentiate u with respect to x don't
need to worry about the constant of 1 it
just differentiates away and then log x
becomes 1 over x now when you have a
think about this if you have a look at
the top back in our original question 1
over x is right there so that's a really
promising sign so thumbs up okay i'm
also going to need to change my
boundaries right there used to be x
equals 1 and x equals 2. so i'm going to
say
when
x equals 1 what do i get out of that i'm
going to say that u is 1 plus log of one
log of one is just zero so i get this
result that's kind of cute x equals one
leads to u equals one
and then when i do x equals two my upper
boundary what do i get same substitution
one plus log 2 but then you say oh
that's it like there's not really much
other way to simplify it so i'm just
going to leave it it looks slightly
messy but that's fine i can substitute
that in and it should come out in my
definite integral
okay so therefore i can say the integral
of and you've seen me do this before and
i like making it very explicit when i'm
changing my boundaries i'm just going to
state what the boundaries used to be
there were x boundaries i've got the dx
on the top
and then on the denominator i've got x 1
plus log x or squared okay what's that
going to be equal to well
here come the boundary so my x equals 1
became u equals 1 and my x equals 2
became u equals 1 plus log 2.
and then uh we just kind of sort of chew
through this bit by bit right you can
see that this one over x hanging out the
front it's just going to be um the
you know the one over x and the dx
together just become d u right so in
fact i'm not going to write this at all
that d u is going to hang out on the end
all you get left with is
this 1 plus log x or squared on the
denominator and i already know what the
1 log x piece is right it's just going
to be
1 over u
squared
and then this 1 over x dx becomes the du
that i saw before okay so i'll just
highlight that you can see
those two things go together
okay so this is great like i've made
this about as easy to integrate as you
can see um you know this is u to the
power of negative 2. maybe you want to
write that line separately but i think
we know what to do with this right i'm
going to raise the power by 1 and then
i'm going to divide by the new power so
that's going to be uh here comes my
square brackets
rather negative u to the power of minus
1
negative 1. you see what i've done there
the negative 2 went up at negative 1 and
i divided by the negative 1. and of
course i've got my boundaries 1 and 1
plus log 2.
okay
what can i do with this well
let's just do our substitution right so
this is actually i guess you could if
you want to just have one less thing in
your brain you can have that minus sign
out the front and then this is just 1
over u right 1
1 plus log 2.
so
here comes the upper boundary it's going
to be minus 1 over 1 plus log 2
and then that lower boundary is going to
be just be careful it's a double
negative happening here because that
negative out the front is going to be
blood plus 1 over 1.
that's it okay so when i look at this
i'm like okay common denominator i
notice that this 1 over 1 i can write as
1 plus log 2 over 1 plus log 2 because
i'm multiplying through by that so it's
a bit sneaky i know
but once you can see that you've got 1
plus log 2 take away 1.
i'm getting that minus 1 from here
and that's all over that common
denominator that i just got 1 plus log
2. so ones cancel log 2 over 1 plus log
2.
there's my result okay
now like i said this is a pretty neat
way to do it but one of the things i
like to do is to try and highlight for
you that well if you if you get to
choose what your substitution is what
happens if you choose something else one
plus log x is not the only choice that
is valid and being that you are dealing
with logarithms you may recall that the
flip side of a logarithm is an
exponential and in fact if you use an
exponential substitution it ends up
being just as straightforward so what
i'm going to do is just to keep things
separate
let's choose something like t right
that's another variable that we tend to
oh another pronun rule that we tend to
use to substitute in as our dummy
variable so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say
let's just call this method 2.
instead of saying
that u equals 1 plus log x what i'm
going to say is well let's just frame
this in terms of exponential so i'm
going to say let say x equal e to the t
and that implies that the log function
is going to be log x equals t so you can
see this is very very similar
i'm sort of getting this
it's still log x appearing it's just not
1 plus log x
and what's going to happen is everything
is going to be in terms of exponential
so it's going to be very very
straightforward to evaluate
okay let's have a go
in exactly the same way i'm going to
number one differentiate to change the
variable of integration and then i'm
also going to get my new boundary so i'm
going to go dx on dt in this case
this is one of those nice things about
an exponential it's just going to be e
to the t
and then i look at my boundaries so what
was it i said x equals 1 was the first
boundary so i'm going to get
1 equals e to the t so clearly t is
going to be 0 for this and then for x
equals 2
i get
2 equals e to the t so t is just going
to be equal to log 2 taking logs of both
sides
okay i'm ready to go i've got all my
pieces so i can say therefore the
integral from uh let's do it again x
equals 1
x equals 2 of 1
over
x 1 plus log x squared
oh yeah i'll leave that dx over there
since i've already written it what's
that going to be equal to well let's uh
pop in our new boundaries first so i'm
going from 0 to log 2
or i should say that's a bit sneaky
wasn't it i should say i'm actually
going
t equals log 2 and t equals 0.
all right and now i just go bit by bit
through the integrand and
and also the
variable of integration so what am i
going to get you can see up the top
there right
that dx is going to become e to the t
dt right can you see them combining
together so i'm going to get e to the t
dt on the top
on the denominator i used to have an x
but i'm substituting that for e to the t
so you can see some cancelling is going
to go on there
and then my 1 plus log x all squared
well i know that log x is just going to
be t right so therefore this just
becomes 1 plus t all squared
that's it so you can see that's going to
cancel that's going to cancel so you're
going to get
from 9 to log 2 of
1 plus t to the power of negative 2 dt
and hopefully this looks familiar i'm
going to do the same thing that i did
before it's sort of reverse chain rule
but it's a very simple reverse chain
rule because your inside derivative is 1
you're going to get
negative 1 plus t to the negative 1 and
i'm going to pop in 0 and log 2. okay so
from here let's have a go
pop that minus sign out the front and
then what you get is i'm going to do my
upper boundary first so it's 1 over 1
plus log 2 does that look familiar and
then i'm subtracting
1 over 1 plus 0 which is 1. and at this
point i'm kind of going to stop because
you're sort of like oh this is deja vu
right at this point here this line of
working is going to very shortly become
this line of working up here so we know
where it goes and of course we end up
with the same result which one is better
i think they're both pretty equivalent
it kind of if your brain went to one or
the other immediately i'd be not fussed
either way but my point here is you can
choose there's not like one right
substitution that gives you the best
answer they will give you the same
answer if you do them correctly and
sometimes they're pretty equivalent
right exponentials and logs
two sides of the same coin